[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Next,
we have Ibrahim,
who is going to be talking
to us about YouTube.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: So who
wants their games go viral?
Anyone?
Who doesn't want their
games to go viral anyways?
So today, I'll talk about
how you can actually
get your games viral with
YouTube and with YouTube APIs.
And then I will dive into
all the specific developer
ideas we have that you can
actually achieve that goal.
And first, let's
talk about YouTube.
Besides being the most public
video-sharing platform,
it's the second-biggest
search engine on the web.
And today, we see 1
billion unique users
visit YouTube every day.
And they watch 6 billion
hours of video every month.
Could they be all
watching cat videos?
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe.
What if I say 25%
percent of them
are actually coming from mobile?
Oh you know what-- I
find the suspect for you.
Here it is.
[LAUGHTER]
You know.
Cats are everywhere.
So from a survey, we found
that people who play videos--
[LAUGHING]
So people who play
video games, 95% of them
say that they're actually
watching the gameplay videos,
as well as the trailers.
So do you see the
opportunity here,
like how you can
actually get to them?
And if you use the
YouTube APIs, you actually
get to all the
YouTube services-- all
these amazing services you
already have and from your app.
And then your game integrates
with YouTube APIs, what
do you think it would create?
It would only
create awesomeness.
[LAUGHTER]
And to actually see all
the different services,
I create the
[INAUDIBLE] into four.
And we'll see all these
different four verticals.
First, Google, through the
creation side, where you're
actually uploading the videos.
Second side will
be discovery, where
you'll find other
interesting videos that
show inside your games.
In the third part
with Analytics,
you will see some
[INAUDIBLE] of those videos.
And finally, we'll talk
about the content management.
Let's start with the upload.
As like "FIFA," like all
the other games right now,
actually helping you
get the instant replays.
So you can easily upload
games from inside your game
without ever leaving it.
Isn't really cool to
show it to your friends
and brag about all
these nice moves you do?
And they use Data API for it.
We have the
[? resume ?] uploads,
where you can upload all
this game content easily
without ever leaving your app.
And besides the games
and consoles already
implementing it, there are
even platforms like Everyplay,
[INAUDIBLE], who are
letting other developers use
the APIs right away, which
is like grabbing frames
and using YouTube APIs and
sending them to YouTube.
For this, they most of the
times use like [? unity ?]
[? to add ?] the [? frames. ?]
And then they encode with
the WebM.
They use the YouTube APIs to
send videos to the YouTube.
And besides the video
on demand, today, we
are also seeing
the live streaming
getting hugely popular.
One of them is the people like
streaming their own games.
And further than that, there
are even these sports, actually
even more popular than the
music festivals nowadays.
Besides all the
games and consoles
are enabling YouTube
Live Streaming API,
they are even in like
the secondary products.
Like Elgato has a
hardware encoder.
Like XSplit is a
software encoder,
which will let you stream your
games while you are playing.
And they're all using
the Live Streaming API,
which you can easily
plug in yourself, as
well into your games and
let your people game-play
and stream it.
And Direct Lite has also
helped you get all these videos
into your own playlist, which
you can administer and show
them later on.
And this was a lot
like the uploads.
I want also talking
about the discovery,
where you would find
interesting videos
and show them inside your games.
Like using the search
inside our Data API,
you can find all
different videos,
even the power of the
Google Knowledge Graph
using Topic APIs.
And from there, once you find
those different videos, maybe
like other little videos, you
can show them inside your game,
like using the Android Player
API, as well as the iFrame API.
For iOS and all the
others resources,
you can easily play
video inside your app.
And you get the video.
Then you want to also see
how your videos are doing.
Maybe that will predict
about your game result.
You can use
Analytics API for it.
This has already happened
in the music business, where
our next big song was predicting
record sales out of the YouTube
videos-- the popular videos
were in the YouTube already.
And if you want do it as well,
you can use Analytics API.
And the last part is the Content
ID API, which you can actually
claim the videos and monetize
them, either monetize
for extra revenue or change
it with other advertisements.
Or you can get
free advertisement
for your own portfolio.
And for that, we've seen
ZEFR making an easy platform
for people who like to claim
videos and monetize them
right over from that.
So today, I just like
in a brief thing,
I've talked about the creation
to upload live-streaming,
in discovery, find videos
and just re-stream them,
and the analytics
side, which you
can get insights, and finally,
the content management,
where you can actually
even monetize them.
And if you want more resources,
we have the YouTube developer
website, youtube.com/dev,
which you can find all the API
resources and even interact
with them [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]